we're joined on the phone now by our
crime correspondent Martin what more can
you tell us
the charges stem from investigations
that we've reported on in the past
um essentially there are charges of
three aggravated rapes and two of sexual
abuse of children these are all
unconnected with the Madeleine McCann
investigation so he remains a suspect
Christian b a suspect for Madeleine
McCann's abduction but he's now facing
extra charges that um that will be
prosecuted
um perhaps the most serious is the rape
of a young Irish woman she was 20 at the
time she was a working as a holiday rep
in prior to Russia along the coast from
prior to luge where Madeleine vanished
this was in 2004 so three years before
Madeleine's disappearance
um the alleged victim here is a woman
who waved her anonymity
um a couple of years ago and spoke about
her ordeal um the allegation or the
charge now says that Christian B broke
into her holiday to the early hours
raped her tied her up attacked her
physically and then raped her a second
time so that's one of uh the incident
another one is the rape of the of an
elderly woman between it is a 70 and 80
in a holiday flat uh those are the three
rapes and there are two allegations of
sex assault one on a 14 year old girl
um Christian B is alleged to have tied
up and whipped
um another sex assault alleged on a 10
year old girl on the beach in The
Algarve and the most recent
um again something that we've reported
on from a village north of the coast on
the Algarve an allegation of now a
charge of Christian B exposing himself
to an 11 year old girl during a festival
in the village I remember talking to the
mother of the alleged victim there a
year or so ago describing Christian B
hiding under a under a child's ride in a
playground the police were called at the
time and he was arrested but he was
deported to Germany and when he got back
to Germany this was in 2017 this is when
the German authorities started
investigating these crimes for which he
has now been charged and will at some
stage appear in court to face those
charges
um Christian B of course and we're not
using his full name because of German
privacy laws he is currently in jail in
Germany serving a seven-year sentence
for the rape of an American woman who
lived in prior to lose the the beach
resort where Madeline disappeared in two
thousand and seven so uh the
investigation into Madeleine's abduction
which is being carried out by the same
German prosecutor that continues there's
no end in sight to that
um the prosecutor has said today there
is no update on his investigation into
Madeleine's disappearance but he's
renewed appeals for Witnesses
to her Disappearance in 2007.
Martin thank you Martin brunt with the
latest there on that breaking news